we love our hoagies we love Wawa yeah
exactly love our cheesesteaks real
Philadelphia as far as Philadelphia
cheesesteaks go Jim's on South Street
would be my favorite
it's definitely Jim's on South Street
I'm a Geno's girl the point is my number
one I'm expecting dry meats and terrible
bread I'm kind of a little worried about
the bread I'm expecting them to be like
either too cheesy
or not cheesy enough where's wet bring
on the first cheesesteak she okay okay
looks like there's provolone on here
it's not whiz
you gotta put way too much I know I'm
gonna sell like fake cheese flavor dummy
you can never get the bread no the bread
I mean there's only one kind of legit
bread and this is not it you can use a
little love there's steak and there's
cheese but it doesn't taste like a
cheesesteak I'm hurt bad I almost tastes
like a cheeseburger I'm gonna give it
four Liberty bells to bells I just want
it to three Liberty bells let's get the
next one
[Music]
Oh sounds a little Messier not a
mushrooms in here this is a panini first
of all is this ciabatta bread that is a
big chunk of steak look how thick that
is what statement I don't know how a
cheese steak
there's move them at though maybe I just
like all cheese sticks kind of negative
Liberty bells taste wise I give it like
four Liberty bells I'd give it to three
the job Denny's some way it's now called
a stub it's called hoagie it looks the
closest thing I'm seeing so far to
Tuesday yeah those jalapenos in here
jalapenos Oh notice that's all he knows
I can't do it pear shape shoved way the
meat is cut better it's not chunky of
the other ones but it's pretty good meat
definitely cut better it definitely has
more of a consistency of a real Philly
cheesesteak it's the closest almost
reminds me of like when your parent
would make cheese steaks for dinner
three bells I hear this one too yeah
I'll give it a three by hoagie way
hooters South Philly cheese wait wait
out of you start have you ever eaten in
a hooters before there's lots of
non-traditional Philadelphia items on
this guy it's a mushroom different
peppers the vegetables are throwing me
off he's kind of like a fajita says if
bread it feels like a baby's bottom the
roll feels a little soft for me in here
it doesn't have a lot of flavor
I guess at Hooters you know the flavor
comes elsewhere I really want some win
it I don't know who would just think
they sorry Hooters I'm gonna give you
your Liberty bells yeah I think this is
your Liberty Bell
I'm Jimmy three hooters got to go dick
to the wings man a lot of people don't
realize it like South Jersey's basically
Philadelphia oh yeah this looks the most
like a cheesesteak Mike don't let me
down the bread is almost perfect I
didn't get with this one mm-hmm easily
the best one okay Jersey Mike this is a
cheesesteak it's not as good as a
cheesesteak from Philly but it does
taste like a cheesesteak he would get
like in New Jersey I would definitely
give this boy Liberty bells make so for
Liberty Bell and as far as the ones
we've had so far this is by far the
thighs yeah no all right yeah
Philly definitely makes the best
cheesesteaks if you're like I know
Philadelphia cheesesteaks stat that many
of those moments Thanks why he goes by
on the road to bake the Reed I love you
wah-wah I miss you